foreign
the queen of a certain kingdom was
Barren though she wished it more than
anything she could not have a child she
kept her sadness hidden in songs and
kindness but the king could discern her
suffering through the smiles for years
she kept her tears to herself her heart
secretly praying for her long desired
child
one day on the Feast of Candlemass a
crow perched in a tree just above her in
the garden startled in her mending the
queen pricked her finger and a drop of
her blood fell onto the pristine snow
she knew at that moment that she would
have a child but her prayers had been
answered she would give birth to the
most beautiful girl in the world with
skin as white as the Virgin Snow with
lips as red as blood and with hair as
black as coal